john's background was so screwed up
between not getting to live with his
mother
you know or father what was that
like i knew his father had left
john and lama and his mother when john
was three
and i knew that was a huge pain for john
growing up
and john went to live with his uncle and
auntie and then the uncle died
and so john confided in me he said you
know i think i i could be a jinx
against the male lion and i had to sort
of talk him down
off the edge you know i said no you're
not that's stupid you know it wasn't
your fault your bloody father left
john did not have a great life in that
department in a family department
so even after his dad's left to three
his mother's got killed in front of the
house he's now staying out
run over by a car and then all those
years later
his dad now shows up and wants money and
i think that led
to a lot of john's angst you know when
he and i were together
there wasn't a lot of that because we
were just friends
and we were doing stuff and we were
being creative
i mean a song like help i remember
sitting down and
writing this with john and
he'd come up with the uh when i was
younger so much young
and i suddenly realized okay well we're
talking about an insecurity
thing but this is great it's a song but
once we've finished it we're very happy
with it but it was only later when i
thought
wow you know what that was a real cry
for hell
he really meant it and there was so many
things like that about john's life that
you know i could sympathize with if john
had a moment of insecurity like we all
do
i would be able to kind of talk to him
about it
i remember him saying what am i going to
be thought of
after i've died what was people going to
think about me
and he was worried about it and i said
you are kidding me
i said you're kidding man you're a
you're a legend already
never mind when you die and i i had to
reassure him
you